[Music]
our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as americans is
far greater than what divides us i love
this series and today we are sharing the
story of an artist who's working to tell
the stories of asian american icons who
are often left out of the history books
and she's doing that by baking that's
right adriana diaz first caught up with
jasmine cho before the pandemic and
before adriana's pregnancy with her soon
to be born baby
it's very meditative jasmine cho is an
avid baker but her confections aren't
necessarily for consumption they're not
really intended to be eaten
they're intended to be digested
internally i like that intellectually
yeah
it's their face it's their identity
digested intellectually because of what
and who they represent
people she's trying to rescue from the
back burners of history asian american
icons who helped shape our country yet
remain largely unknown yes so this is
afong moy the first chinese woman to
immigrate to america and she was
basically brought over to be showcased
to the world
almost like a circus freak show sammy
lee was the first asian american to win
a gold medal for the u.s in olympic
diving he had to practice his diving
into a sand pit
because he was barred from entering the
public pools in his neighborhood so i
always use a little bit of this dust
jasmine bakes modern icons too like
actors aquafina keanu reeves and in case
you haven't guessed give him a little
definition star trek's george takei her
sugar cookies are being exhibited at
pittsburgh state edmonds academy where
marianne lien directs education on
inclusion and global awareness
when you first saw jasmine's cookies
what did you think
i thought so
brilliant so creative so colorful so
everything that i want the world to
think and see of us
we didn't get to see
the cookies captivate students they sit
still for a moment to think well but
it's a cookie
it's about something that's so serious
and so then you know that struggle then
starts to make just a little more
indentation in the brain growing up in
los angeles as the daughter of korean
immigrants jasmine was bullied over race
everyone was always throwing so many
racial slurs at me everything that you
can think of like go back to your your
country that sense of exclusion deepened
in school given the lack of asian
american stories in textbooks but then a
college elective filled the blanks i
remember even as a kid i thought why are
we only always like two percent to five
percent of america's population and then
i learned about all these exclusion laws
that barred every demographic of asian
people from coming into the country
based on race and i'm like oh that's why
on campus at jasmine's alma mater carlow
university can we do a quick pop quiz we
tested students knowledge
most had trouble identifying the
portraits
but some recognized jasmine i saw you at
a tedx event oh yeah
yes this is my pride and joy grace lee
boggs she was a chinese-american
activist her university even invited her
to create a mural the significance is
not lost on her
it's just
yeah i can't even it's overwhelming yeah
i can't like you okay yeah i know i i
haven't been able to really like even
look at this because it
it means a lot you know these are the
stories and
everything that i really yearn for
throughout my life and then to have the
honor of being in the position to
actually create it
and to create something that's so
everlasting
i'm just
very honored for cbs this morning
adriana diaz pittsburgh
a big thank you to jasmine so many
things that we didn't or i didn't know
and that we're all learning that's why
these kind of stories are so important
i'm so glad that adriana did that one
for us yeah the notion that you know we
have people who contributed to the
fabric of our society and we don't know
their names the way we know right other
names i like what they said but it's a
cookie but it's so serious but it's a
cookie and that's in that struggle is
the art jasmine making a difference
right